hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development for februari fifth 2013 it's
been a while since the last this week's
in Android development but just because
we haven't been recording video updates
doesn't mean we haven't been hard at
work creating new Android developer
resources so like the 49ers after a
power blackout we're returning stronger
than ever and there'll be no holding us
back since you last saw us there's been
two updates to Google Play services
including the long-awaited update to map
view featuring support for vector maps
pan and tilt and map fragments we also
launched dev bites with the first six
episodes of these five minute video
tutorials featuring the many moods of
Chet Haase you can find them all at bit
ly / dev bites Android developers live
was in hiatus over the holiday period
but we're back with the Roman Adam and
Nick kicking off 2013 with their second
Android design in action hang out last
week in e lewis and a lesser version of
louis theroux launched the pure android
collection on last friday's app clinic
with apps tasks and pattern the first
inductees granted admission into this
exclusive club in android developers
live this week Nick Roman and Adam are
back for another Android design in
action with a look at soccer apps and a
deep dive into creating distinctive
Launcher icons are European advocates
are back on Wednesday for their first
half hour office hours and tune into atl
plus live from Sydney with special focus
on analytics featuring right from the ad
works dev rel team finally on Friday in
and a less talented version of Muse
frontman Matthew Bellamy will host an
app clinic dedicated to soccer team
tracking apps fought mob spory and game
plan are any good enough to be pure
Android tune in and find out if you'd
like the opportunity to get near enough
a developer advocate to smell our
passion for app development join dr.
Fibonacci as he presents storm live at
the london android usergroup on februari
7 in app releases and updates this week
we saw a new release from USA Today
Steve Jackson's house of hell an update
from clothes store hmm and a new tablet
app update for health tap that's all for
this week in Android development we look
forward to you joining us for a many
live shows this week and remember a
gloomy December will brighten by May and
you're on your way my name is reto Meier
thanks for watching
you